buonasera nel mio paese c'è una strada
che si chiama via della barriera e un
giorno chiesto il perché del nome di
questa strada ed è lì è venuta la storia
che adesso vi racconto la storia di un
viaggio un tempo a viaggiare erano gli
uomini ma anche una ragazzetta parti dai
muti sola la guerra non era ancora
cominciata
e l'inverno era appena finito la mattina
che se ne andò sta con lo specchio da
sopra l'acquario prese il rosario da
cavalletto e si mise in tasca gli
orecchini di corallo e poi via senza
salutare nessuno sentì nodo alla gola
mentre passava la soglia di casa lo
senti anche a scendere le scale e poi
attraverso l'aia e non senti più nulla
affidò i viottoli a quello che avrebbe
voluto la santa vergine non si era mai
allontanata dal casolare il tetto
d'ardesia poche stanze buie affumicate
il ronzio fitto delle mosche tra il
passo delle forbici e il caso nei nomi
che li conosce solo la gente di lì un
posto da rookie senza una piazzetta una
chiesina nulla intorno ai boschi e sopra
il sano e lei stava lì sotto il cielo
sotto il tetto d'ardesia né bella né
brutta secca secca con un foularino in
testa che nessuno le aveva mai visto i
capelli di filiera la più grande i suoi
run carbonai una famiglia chiusa
sembravano nati per tribolare e basta a
sette anni in piedi su un panchetto
perché altrimenti non arrivava all'acqua
io facevo i piatti è finito di
rigovernare andava la fonte a prendere
l'acqua neve vento toccava a lei era lei
che faceva il bucato al fiume con la
lisciva nell'acqua gelata che a volte
non sentiva neanche più le manine e era
lei che di notte veniva svegliata dalla
nonna o vi limba levatevi si dice un'ave
maria la madonna dopo ci si riaddormenta
dino mani giunte sul comodino c'era un
piatto coperto con la carta gialla e un
coltello pregavano e poi la vecchia
prendeva il piatto c'era una fetta di
pane del burro che un trisolino di
zucchero metteva il burro sul pane lo
zucchero sopra e poi siccome non aveva i
denti per masticare con il coltello
incideva tutta la crosta intorno e se lo
mangiavano insieme a pezzetti e la bimba
si addormentava con quel dolce dello
zucchero in bocca era l'unica dolcezza
che le toccava perché in casa sua non
erano avvezzi a certe cose e alle le
dispiaceva di non esser mai presa sulle
ginocchia mai un complimento mai un
bacino a volte avrebbe voluto esser lei
andargli intorno strusciarsi come in
quella casa faceva solo il gatto ma si
accorgeva di essere vergognosa come loro
era venuta su così senza tante moine e
con due cose da temere dispiacere alla
madonna e la cinghia di suo padre
una mattina suo padre rientro
bestemmiando aveva la mano avvolta in
uno straccio sanguinava sarà portato via
le dita col pennato resto a casa pochi
giorni sembrava una beast in gabbia
quel pomeriggio erano soli in casa lei
sa fare piatte lui è seduta al tavolo
quando le disse di spicciarsi che dopo
gli doveva fare la barba
la bimba si voltò e vide che aveva già
il rasoio in mano e seguito a fare
piatte zitta poi si avvicino al babbo
prese lo specchio da sopra la cuoio e
glielo mise nella mano buona mentre
bagnava le setole che si gonfiavano col
sapone il pub o spiegava come fare e poi
appoggia la testa indietro
e allora il pennello coprì il viso di
schiuma presi e rasoio occhio bimba che
qui un set ea fa l'eco marelle questo
qui taglia da vero era la prima volta
che teneva in mano una cosa così da
maschi entrò con la lama nella schiuma
appoggio alla scala ma alla carne e
lascio andare la mano che scivolò libera
dagli zigomi a in mento lasciando sulla
pelle una striscia liscia come una
strada venne tutto da se ci sono delle
sapienze che non si porta dentro senza
neanche conoscerle e lei quel giorno
scopri la sua
alla fine il babbo toccando si faceva
segno che anche per lui era stata brava
non aveva ancora 12 anni e la mandarono
al servizio in una famiglia che
toccarono gli stessi lavori di casa
compreso la barba al marito della
signora perché i suoi quando la
raccomandarono lo dissero che aveva
l'estro per fare la barbiera ci restò
parecchi anni il necessario per fare la
barba era in una bella scatola di latta
russa il giorno che scappò era un giorno
pensato tante volte scappò dunque il
lavoro la mattina da casa sua aveva
portato via lo specchio da sopra l'acqua
e dalla signora robot la scatola di
latta portò via anche un asciugamano una
forchetta di pecorino era lì lì per
prender delle uova invece agguanta una
gallina era già sul trespolo a dormire
fu questione di un attimo la mise nel
sacco e via senza far chiasso ma alla
domenica avanti si era alzata per tempo
era andata a san pellegrino con un sasso
grosso così
sanpellegrino rimaneva nell'altro
versante e le cominciò a camminare tra i
boschi con il sasso in una cesta sulle
spalle
san pellegrino e in alto e in cima alla
montagna è un borgo di case su un'unica
strada e su quella strada c'è il
santuario o le spoglie di san pellegrino
san pellegrino era figlio di un re ma
rinunciò alla corona si mise in viaggio
e da qui il nome pellegrino finché
guidato da una stella arrivo lassù sui
monti dove anche il diavolo lo segue il
diavolo era così arrabbiato con
quest'uomo perché non cedeva le sue
tentazioni che un giorno gli d'este uno
schiaffo così forte da farlo girare per
tre volte e per la potenza di quello
schiaffo tutta la terra tremò si
staccarono dei sassi dalmonte e oggi li
nel punto dello schiaffo di sassi ce n'è
una distesa la portati la gente per
devozione
più pesante il senso di colpa più grosso
il sasso e prima di riporlo per tre
volte in ginocchio si fa il giro
dell'intera distesa alla ragazza arrivò
su stremata e si mise a girare con i
ginocchi che si sbronzo lavano e alla
fine si strinse al sasso o san
pellegrino benedetto
perdonatemi le colpe aiutatemi a scappa
guida team ivo per i monti perché io le
vie all'infuori di torno casa un nesso e
dove andrò a fini fatemi ci arriva
strana abbiate misericordia di me un cio
dormito annotata riuscì nacci un ne
posso più ti sta qui ho quindi set è
andato di casa e potevi tessere mi
capite no aiutate anche mi premi ma loro
mi capiranno mai ve lo posso qui il
sasso dati mela la forza di ritornarci
quassù vivo bene
la pietra un po di saliva sui ginocchi e
via con le spalle più leggere e con
l'anima pesante e con l'anima pesante il
fagotto di cose rubate la gallina nel
sacco quella sera prese per i viottoli
per non tornare più in casa sua se ne
sarebbero accorti dopo un po potevano
disperarsi maledire il destino ma non
c'era tempo da perdere a cercarla il
buio le entrava dentro insieme ai
rimorsi stava stretta con tata rosario
lo ripeteva di continuo un'ave maria
dopo l'altra graffi scivolate non
sentiva nulla solo gli scossoni della
gallina che si dimenava nel sacco
spaventata come lei ci vuole del tempo
per scollegare arrivava di là da un
monte e ne vedeva un altro accorse che
era la piana perché era tutto tutto
tutto libero e là in fondo e il mare non
l'aveva mai visto se l'era immaginata
tante volte ma anche adesso che era
vicina non ci andò ce n'era di cose
prima di andare a vedere il mare la
strada divideva la piana in due e di qua
e di là nel mezzo c'erano i casolari le
galline le mucche e le sembrò tutto
sparpagliato sui monti era più unita era
più raccolto fece caso un ghiotto letto
lungo un fosso sarà un bel l'albero di
fico sotto un tronco tagliato basso
gente non ce n'era ma lì venne lo stesso
di nascondersi disse un'altra volta il
rosario e poi solo mise al collo andò
sotto il fico e senti che era arrivata
lascia libera la gallina che lì per lì
non si mosse mezza stordita attacco allo
specchio a un ramo del fico e graffiando
sulla scatola di latta ci scrisse barak
e la barbiera cominciò a rasare i maschi
della piana con la gente che parlava
poco venuta dal nulla
cominciò a rasare contadini e marinai di
lei sapevano che vendi per il sud a
monti e large ne ha fatto orme del
granaio basta gli uomini presero
abitudine di trovarsi sotto al fico era
il sabato il giorno della barba fatta
come si deve
nei capelli impomatati di brillantina
finito 1 scuoteva l'asciugamano da via
sotto un altro non sorrideva non dava
confidenza gli occhi bassi ma aveva un
tocco sotto il fico in parole discorsi
dei maschi perché mentre radeva 1 gli
altri parlavano del prezzo delle sementi
dei viaggi verso il brasile l'argentina
per cambiar vita alzavano la voce
lei faceva finta di nulla oppure
parlavano della domenica nell'aia a
ballare all'organetto le piaceva
ascoltare sotto il fico imparò anche i
ragionamenti dei marinai e marinai erano
diversi dagli altri uomini avevano visto
così tanto mondo mamma mia
quando lo raccontavano sembrava
inventato e poi fischiavano sempre tutti
gli uomini fischiettavano li vedevi
arrivare sulle biciclette sembravano
degli usignoli ma i marinai di più per i
marinai il fischio era proprio un modo
per comunicare c'era una fischiata che
era dei marinai versiliesi solo di
quelli e se gli capitava di trovarsi in
un posto lontano dove non conoscevano la
lingua e fischiavano in quel modo lì se
c'era un altro versiliese col fischio si
trovavano e poi marinai avevano anche un
altro d'ore
perché a forza di stare accostata ai
maschi hanno imparato l'odore della
pelle dei maschi l'aveva catalogati
nella sua mente i marinai avevano
catrame e salmastro non si sentiva altro
soldi non ne vedeva però gli portavano
il pane
la verdura l'uva una volta proprio un
marinaio il portò un romanzo un librone
di tela lei non era spedita a leggere
per capire una frase la doveva ripetere
tante volte a voce alta
poi però s'appassiona entrò nella storia
lo lesse sei o sette volte il libro
avrebbe voluto leggerne altri ma non ci
fu un modo accade una mattina arriva a
bocciando un gruppo di spose non c'era
nessuno a quell'ora per la barba o
sudicia tenetevi andati più inteso tanto
gli uomini con te non ce lo fanno
l'amore con te ci vogliono gode e basta
schifosa e la spinsero e la fecero
cadere e lei voleva parlare e spiegarsi
ma le parole e si bloccavano nella gola
quelle bocche spalancate senza grazia
che sembrava se la mangiassero le
ricordavano la colpa vera l'unico
rimorso essere scappata di casa e non
essersene pentita mai foulard geni a
farle smettere
senti il baccano e arrivò di corsa aria
via solare ci penso e alle ricordatevi
che questa ragazza una fatto nulla di
male
restò con il braccio teso
finché non si furono allontanate la
domenica dopo la videro con cesarino
cambiati erano andati dal prete fu lei a
dirgli del brasile aveva sentito di
gente partita con nulla che laggiù sarà
fatta una posizione si imbarcarono a
dicembre le per l'occasione si mise gli
orecchini di corallo tolse la pezzola
dai capelli aveva una bella trezza
dietro stava bene nel mio paese a forte
dei marmi
c'è una strada che si chiama via della
barbiera le origini del nome di questa
strada sono vaghe
qualcuno dice che viene da barriera
perché una strada vicino al confine tra
due comuni
qualcuno dice che viene da barberi e un
cognome tipico della zona ma i più
sostengono che in quella strada quando
era ancora un viottolo c'era una donna
che faceva la barba sotto il fico